Ant-Man and the Wasp gave fans another look
at the size-changing shenanigans of Paul Rudd's
Ant-Man and added in more characters, more
action, and equal billing for Evangeline Lilly's
Wasp.
As you might expect for a movie about characters
that shrink down to micro-size, there were
some very small details that you might have
missed.
From a reference to an obscure comic character
to a classic sci-fi movie shout out, here
are even smaller details you may have missed
in Ant-Man and the Wasp.
"Here's the deal.
Just give me the facts."
"Just the facts.
Only the facts."
"Breathe.
Focus.
Keep it simple."
"No doubt, no doubt."
X-Con Security solutions
The plot of Ant-Man and the Wasp is focused
on saving Janet Van Dyne from the Quantum
Realm, but we also see what Scott's been doing
since the last film.
He's started a small business with Luis and
company: X-Con, a security consulting service.
It's a reference straight from 2015's Ant-Man
comic series, in which Scott Lang starts a
security consulting service: "Ant-Man Security
Solutions."
The biggest difference besides the names is
that the comics version features the Grizzly,
a giant bear-man ex-supervillain, as his business
partner-slash-employee.
Here's hoping that this particular detail
somehow makes it into the next Ant-Man movie
as well.
"I wish I had a suit.
Even with like minimal powers."
"Or maybe even just a suit with no powers."
Who wouldn't want to see Michael Peña suit
up in a giant bear costume on the big screen?
Eye see what you did there
Early in the film, Scott builds an obstacle
course for his daughter out of cardboard.
That bit of father-daughter bonding might
be adorable, but it also hides a reference
to one of Marvel's strangest villains: the
Orb.
In order to crack the "retinal scanner" that
Scott has assembled, Cassie has to put on
a giant eyeball mask, which looks suspiciously
similar to the Orb, a Marvel supervillain
whose head is a giant eyeball.
While it seems like a bit of a stretch, the
Orb actually became a pretty major player
in the last decade of Marvel Comics.
In 2014's Original Sin storyline, he successfully
steals an eye from the cosmic deity, the Watcher,
forces dozens of heroes to confront long-buried
secrets, and even becomes a pseudo-Watcher
himself.
Is Cassie's mask a hint that there's another
enemy for the Avengers to fight after Thanos
is taken care of?
We'll have to keep our eyes peeled.
Magic man
Scott's struggle to keep Cassie entertained
while he's under house arrest involves more
than just building giant cardboard obstacle
courses: he also becomes an expert at sleight
of hand thanks to an online magic course.
It's no wonder that Scott becomes pretty good
at magic, since his online teacher is actually
played by an expert magician: Blake Vogt.
"Watch, ready?"
Vogt has made a name for himself as a magic
consultant on movies like Now You See Me,
and he contributes his expertise to Ant-Man
and the Wasp as well.
He even cameos as Scott's online teacher,
briefly visible while Scott, and later FBI
agent Jimmy Woo, are learning close-up magic.
You know what this means, don't you?
Now Dr. Strange isn't the only magic user
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"So, Earth has, uh, wizards now?"
Really small details
While size-changing was a big part of the
original Ant-Man, the sequel makes the Pym
Particles an even bigger part of the story.
Hank Pym has a laboratory that shrinks down
into a piece of luggage, complete with a handle
and wheels for maximum convenience.
The Quantum Tunnel that they construct to
save Janet from the Quantum Realm is a fun
mix of low and high-tech, combining intricate
computer parts with small items enlarged to
match.
"I like the idea that Hank Pym is not Tony
Stark.
It's not super sleek high tech.
It's sort of glued together, and he uses a
lot of found objects."
Keep your eyes peeled in the movie for giant
volume knobs that help calibrate Janet's location,
giant bread clips holding wires together,
and plenty of other enlarged household objects
used for the Quantum Tunnel.
It might be true that one man's trash is another
man's treasure, but it's probably a bit more
convenient when that trash is expanded to
giant size.
The Matrix
Laurence Fishburne is an accomplished actor
who's appeared in dozens of movies, and, well,
this…
"Ooooweeee!"
...but he's arguably best-known for playing
Morpheus, the mysterious leader of the freedom
fighters in The Matrix.
Fishburne's Bill Foster doesn't share too
many qualities with the martial arts master
Morpheus, but Ant-Man and the Wasp still has
a small reference to Fishburne's most famous
role.
When Scott, Hank, and Hope go to convince
Bill to help them track down Pym's stolen
technology, Bill is teaching a class on quantum
entanglement, and the blackboard behind him
is covered with mathematical equations.
One equation right next to Bill's head in
the shot even includes the word "Matrix."
As Keanu Reeves' Neo would say:
"Woah."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!